nothing makes a statement like a tank in
your backyard and on July 11th you can
buy one more than 100 tanks will be
auctioned from a family estate in
Portola Valley California just steps
away from Silicon Valley the foundation
was formed in 1998 by Jacques
Littlefield
he went from a casual start in the 70s
to by the mid 90s he is purchasing and
collecting more than one tank a week
from around the world
Littlefield had no military background
each thought tanks were interesting
these tanks in here represent multiple
countries multiple years multiple Wars
and multiple battles a portion of the 30
million dollar collection will soon roll
east to a new home in Stowe
Massachusetts transporting a fleet of
military vehicles across the country
cost millions and the auction is to help
fund the move and while they may look
intimidating your neighbors can rest
assured most of the tanks can no longer
fire real ammunition
Drock said that collecting tank is like
eating popcorn you can't have just one
you may agree after seeing these
you